heute ist dieser top-diplomat wangier in
Moskau erwartet worden wie ist das ganze
nun einzuschätzen können wir jetzt
hoffen dass er dort tatsächlich
Gespräche geführt hat um einer
Friedensregelung für die Ukraine näher
zu kommen oder ging es vielleicht dabei
um etwas ganz anderes was ist ihre
Einschätzung
starkes Signal auch das hier an der
Seite Putins steht am Jahrestag in
Moskau aufzutreten er spricht natürlich
Bände und die Hoffnung hier auf einen
Friedensplan aus Peking scheint mir doch
sehr verfehlt hat es recht deutlich
gesagt es geht darum die chinesische
Position für eine mögliche politische
Lösung des Konflikts zu klären also es
geht da erstmal darum dass China die
Initiative ergreift um Vorwürfen auch
entgegen zu treten dass es sozusagen
einen Beistand ein Zuschauer in diesen
Konflikt ist da geht's auch natürlich
darum Vorwürfen aus der Europäischen
Union und aus anderen Teilen der Welt
entgegen zu treten dass man
möglicherweise gar einen unterstütze
oder Profiteur des Krieges im Moment ist
also insofern geht um die Interessen
Chinas und die sind eng verwoben mit
denen in Moskau und mit guten
Sven Odenthal stellt sie über Youtube
über Facebook gerade die Frage gibt es
denn schon nähere Informationen über die
von China aus sich gestellte
Friedensinitiative wie könnte die genau
aussehen sie sagen also so konkret ist
das noch gar nicht sondern ein ausloten
aber warum werden diese Worte die wir ja
eben von wangi doch gehört haben von der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz warum
genau das gerade jetzt
erstmal wir wissen in etwa was wir zu
erwarten haben nämlich zum einen hat nie
darauf verwiesen dass die Worte seines
Chefs nämlich das Partei und Staatschefs
sein dazu Geld haben es geht darum diese
Position zu wiederholen und da haben wir
ja schon einige Evidenz dafür was das
mit sich bringt es geht darum zum
Beispiel zu wiederholen dass China davor
waren nukleare Drogen oder gar den
Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen
da zum Einsatz zu bringen oder auch den
Schutz von nuklearen Einrichtungen oder
Gefahr von chemischen Angriffen
beispielsweise
betont das sind alles Dinge zu denen
sich in einer seit Jahren oder
Jahrzehnten zum Teil verpflichtet hat
also insofern keine Neuigkeiten es wird
auch wieder betont werden territoriale
Integrität Souveränität Prinzipien der
Vereinten Nationen natürlich welche die
gerade massiv gebrochen werden durch den
Angriff Russlands in der Ukraine also
insofern wir müssen wir wissen schon
etwas was wir uns da einstellen müssen
warum jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt
mein Gefühl ist China ist durchaus unter
Druck jetzt etwas da aus dem
Hintertreffen zu kommen global hat sich
doch die Meinung die Position auch
vieler Staaten die vielleicht latent an
der Seite der bricks der Brasiliens
Russlands Italiens Chinas standen also
insbesondere in Brasilien gibt es
Bewegung sich auch stärker zu
positionieren und in der Europäischen
Union wird auf allen Seiten klar gemacht
dass wenn China sich nicht bewegt in
diesem Konflikt eben zunehmen Peking
auch im Fahrwasser Russland gesehen wird
und das ist etwas was natürlich
mittelfristig nicht im Interesse Pekings
ist
jetzt kommt die spannende Frage von
Niklas Kopf angenommen die angekündigten
Friedensbemühungen Chinas würden wie
gehofft eingeleitet also Peking würde es
ernst meinen wäre dies denn dann auch
ein Zeichen was sozusagen anders gibt
auf Entspannung oder die Eskalation in
Bezug auf Taiwan zu hoffen
das sehe ich nicht noch mal die Führung
verfolgt sehr klare eigene Interessen
damit da geht es hier durchaus darum
sein gegenüber den USA klare Kante zu
zeigen gegenüber anderen Partnern oder
vermeintlichen Partnern zu versuchen zu
signalisieren dass man einen
verlässlicher oder ein möglicher Partner
sein kann Rückschlüsse auf Chinas
Friedenswille mit Blick auf Thailand
würde ich daraus nicht ziehen da geht es
um eine deutlich größer und schwieriger
Dynamik die mit seiner eigenen Logik
betrachtet ist und da geht's auch eben
um den Einsatz von Gewalt der als letzte
andere auch im Raum steht
versuchen wir noch mal mit Ihnen diese
Beziehung diese Position China Moskau zu
analysieren man könnte ja sagen ja Tina
redet jetzt von Frieden schickt wangi
nach Moskau um auf Frieden auf
Möglichkeiten zu drängen weil vielleicht
die Ding der Geduldsfaden reißt weil
vielleicht China sagt so langsam muss
jetzt auch mal Ruhe im Karton sein und
das ganze dieser Krieg zu einem Ende
kommen
andererseits sehen wir das ähm ja
Russland isoliert ist aber China immer
noch der Unterstützer ist Russland wäre
ja ganz schlecht dran wenn China
wenigstens wirtschaftlich nicht Russland
unterstützen würde und dann ist er ja
auch noch diese Männer Freundschaft
zwischen hier und Putin insofern wie
sehen Sie das Ganze
es ist eine zentrale Beziehung für beide
Staaten tatsächlich die Dimension der
beiden Führer dort spielt eine wichtige
Rolle das ist ein sicherlich eine tiefe
Beziehung die geprägt ist von einem
gemeinsamen Weltbild von Paranoia von
einer Ablehnung der USA insbesondere
aber die chinesische russische
Beziehungen sind natürlich auch einfach
die von sehr sehr gewichtigen
Nachbarstaaten den es erst in den
letzten 20 Jahren gelungen ist auch von
Grenzstreitigkeiten beispielsweise
abzusehen da hat sich die Beziehung
vertieft in der gemeinsamen Ablehnung
gegenüber dem Westen auch in dem Versuch
alternative Ordnung voranzutreiben und
durch eine durchaus insbesondere für
Russland wichtige sehr wichtige
ökonomische Beziehung im Energiebereich
aber eben auch durch militärische
Lieferung
wie sehen denn diese Lieferungen an
China aus will noch mal darauf kommen
was US-Außenminister blinken gesagt hat
er hatte also einen größte Sorge dass
China Waffen liefern könnte
wirtschaftlich steht China Russland zur
Seite aber wie sieht es denn aus was
wird denn geliefert was wissen Sie wenn
es hier und da heißt ja Mikrochips
werden vielleicht oder Mikroelektronik
wird geliefert die kann man in den Handy
einbauen die kann man die Mikrowelle
einbauen aber die dient ja vielleicht
auch in einem Panzer zu bauen was wissen
sie Überlieferungen ja erstmal muss man
feststellen dass vieles davon sich im
Raum des spekulativen befindet und das
sicherlich eher die Geheimdienste sind
die dort mehrere Erkenntnisse haben es
ist bekannt dass China durchaus
militärische Güter liefert die sind
nicht letal und eher sozusagen im
Bereich der Ausrüstung zu finden das
findet sich selbst im statistischen
Daten wieder das Ausmaß davon ist jetzt
nicht unglaublich ausgeprägt da geht's
wahrscheinlich pro Monat um entweder
etwa eine Millionen US-Dollar von Gütern
die geliefert werden dass es
nachgewiesen es gibt auch Hinweise auf
umgehungshandel über Armenien über
aserba Aserbaidschan über andere Staaten
drohnenteile Ausrüstung
Navigationssysteme und ähnliches all das
ist relativ gut belegt aber das genaue
Ausmaß davon und natürlich auch die
Frage wie viel kommt als nächstes
darüber gibt es unsererseits wenig
gesicherte Erkenntnis
aber es scheint wirklich viele User hier
zu bewegen ich schreibe über Youtube was
hätte denn China davon wenn es Russland
im Krieg gegen die Ukraine mit Waffen
und Geld unterstützt
erstmal ist Peking nicht unbedingt als
Profiteur dieser großen und der
zunehmend gefährlichen Krise zu sehen
china hat grundsätzlich einen Interesse
dass dieser Krieg nicht eskaliert es
gibt eine gewisse was zynische Logik
natürlich dass die USA gebunden sind
jetzt auch durch diesen Konflikt in
Europa aber ich würde jetzt nicht so
weit gehen zu sagen dass China direkt am
Profiteur von dieser auseinandersetzt
also insofern Waffenlieferungen oder die
Lieferung von militärischen
ausrüstungsgütern sind aus der
Perspektive Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
schlicht und einfach dazu
weiterhin Geschäfte zu machen aber
natürlich auch sozusagen nicht im Regen
stehen zu lassen china möchte das
Russland in diesen Krieg ähm nicht zum
verlieren wird dieses Interesse ist klar
geäußert aus der Perspektive Pekings ist
der Hauptschuldige oder die Ursache
dieses Krieges in der NATO Expansion und
dem Verhalten der USA zu sehen also
insofern Kinder steht das Fest an Moskau
Seite stärken ohne aber eben das ist der
Versuch im Westen den Rücken zu wenden
das fast Andreas Böhme hier in anderen
Worten zusammen ist genau der Gedanke er
schreibt über Youtube China interessiert
nur das Geschäft und man kann sich nicht
vorstellen dass man sich das Geschäft
mit dem Westen oder dass man das
Geschäft mit dem Westen riskiert also
wie sie es eben sagen als Bild Moskau
den Rücken stärken aber dem Westen nicht
den Rücken zu wenden also die Geschäfte
weiter machen eine rein ja theoretische
Frage noch mal hier von ich über Youtube
was für schwere Waffen würde denn die
Volksrepublik China im Falle einer
russischen Unterstützung senden was
könnte denn China senden wahrscheinlich
ist das Repertoire und das ja Angebot
groß
ja aber noch mal wir müssen erstmal
festhalten das halten wir stand jetzt
nicht für das wahrscheinlichste Ort
kommt die Indizien die geliefert worden
sind bislang deuten eher auf Gespräche
in die sowas theoretisch in den Raum
stellen
sicherlich benötigt würden von Russland
allerlei Ersatzteile für Flugzeuge für
Panzer
Drohnen wären sicherlich hoch auf der
Liste dafür gibt es Hinweise dass der
Teile zumindest geliefert worden sind
also insofern ich Shoppingliste wäre
sicherlich groß aber noch mal ich finde
es sehr wichtig dass wir hier nüchtern
bleiben und darauf schauen stand jetzt
ist es im Wesentlichen nicht literales
militärisches ausrüstungszeug was
geliefert worden ist und er erzählt hat
ja auch gesagt bisher sind keinerlei
Beweise
vorgelegt worden man muss natürlich auch
die Worte von dem US Außenminister genau
sehen der eben sagt dass man
Informationen hat dass man eventuell
eine Bereitstellung tödlicher
Unterstützung erwogen werden würde
haben sie völlig recht müsste man also
vorsichtig sein trotzdem ist es ja sehr
interessant was nun gestern was heute
passiert ist rote Linien sind klar
gezogen worden MRT Wissen hat ja auch
analysiert und gesagt das ist die
Politik von beiden auch von China dass
man eben sich klipp und klar sagte woran
man ist was vielleicht hilfreich ist nun
ist klipp und klar gesagt worden sollte
China Waffen liefern sollte diese rote
Linie überschritten werden dann äh das
haben die USA glasklar gedroht würden es
Sanktionen der schärfsten Form geben
immer hat uns ja auch erklärt ein Paket
wurde bereit liegen und die EU das haben
wir auch eben gehört Borell hat es
gesagt andere eben auch dann würde die
EU ebenfalls Sanktionen verhängen jetzt
schauen wir mal ganz kurz da drauf
welche Folgen das denn hätte wie sieht
denn die Handelsbilanz der Handel mit
China aus da sehen wir die USA
importieren im Wert von 537 Milliarden
Dollar aus China dem gegenüber stehen
Exporte nach China in Höhe von 154
Milliarden Dollar unterm Strich also ein
Handelsbilanzdefizit in Höhe von 383
Milliarden Dollar ähnlich der Handel der
EU mit China die Exporte mit 562
Milliarden Dollar gut doppelt so hoch
wie die Importe sprich ein
Handelsdefizit der EU mit China von 277
Milliarden Dollar jetzt Nummer
angenommen Herr rotary es käme zu einem
Konflikt des käme also zu Sanktionen wen
würde das denn dann am meisten treffen
oder beide gleich
erstmal müssen wir feststellen dass das
ein Super-GAU gleich kämen das wie die
Worte jetzt nicht zu drastisch wählen
aber eine Kernschmelze der globalen
Wirtschaft wird wäre Implikationen davon
hier würden alle so schwer getroffen
dass das abwägen wie es vielleicht
stärker trifft dann aus meiner
Perspektive in sekundärer Gedanke ist
mit so einem
sanktions-szenario würden wir uns in
einer Abwärtsspirale Bewegen von der
alle betroffen werden und im übrigen
natürlich die Frage in welcher Form
durch die EU wirklich ganz konkret
anschließen würde ist für mich nicht
ganz ausgemacht ich glaube nicht dass
wir hier vollständige Einigkeit in der
Europäischen Union derzeit haben aber es
ist natürlich wichtig dass ich alle
Seiten auch möglichst rational darauf
vorbereiten welche Risiken von so einem
Szenario ausgehen ich hoffe sehr dass
der chinesischen Seite das auch bewusst
ist weil in der Tat natürlich wäre aus
China dramatischen schwer davon
betroffen ich glaube es geht nicht darum
jetzt sozusagen in dem ersten
sanktionsschritt dann gleich größere
Kaliber dort aufzufahren sondern würde
wahrscheinlich versuchen da Schritt für
Schritt in so ein Szenario reinzutreten
aber ich kann mir schwer vorstellen dass
so etwas kalkulierbar und dann auch noch
kontrollierbar ist
aber es sind eben genau die Sorgen die
hier auch User haben Uher Audio schreibt
über Youtube wie könnten denn Sanktionen
gegen China im Ernstfall Aussehen wir
sind doch total abhängig von China und
umgekehrt brauchen die Chinesen eben
auch den Handel mit uns das heißt wie
sie eben sagen eigentlich eine Sache die
von beiden Seiten unvorstellbar wäre
also man würde versuchen wahrscheinlich
erst mal gezielter vorzugehen da gibt es
Listen von Gütern bei denen China
besonders verletzlich wäre da würde man
versuchen den Druck zu erhöhen das gelbe
sozusagen eine sanktionslogik die
versucht bestimmte Akteure zu treffen so
kennt man das ja also nicht so wie man
das auch Russland gemacht aber wir
wissen natürlich auch wie schwer es ist
auch mit den Sanktionen gegenüber
Russland Wirkung oder gar unmittelbare
Wirkung zu erzielen also insofern noch
mal dass es in höchster verkehrsszenario
ähm vor dem sich alle hoffentlich
scheuen werden dass tatsächlich das zu
Realität wird und vor allen Dingen haben
wir ja jetzt schon mit Russland das
Beispiel ja deutlich gesehen dass das
ganze irgendwie fast aus dem Ruder läuft
weil auf einmal Menschen im Sudan
hungern und man das ja gar nicht mehr
sozusagen kontrollieren kann wie Preise
sich entwickeln weltweit also das ganze
einzufangen Sanktionen würde ja auch für
alle bitte Beteiligten schwierig richtig
absolut in der Tat und wir sind jetzt
beim zehnten Sanktionspaket gegenüber
Russland die Vorstellung dass wir in so
einer Spirale mit China reinkommt noch
mal das ist etwas wo wir alle viel daran
setzen sollten dass das nicht dazu kommt
die Verantwortung liegt natürlich primär
jetzt dazu hin
ja es gibt auch Kommentare
UTS schreibt über Youtube redet endlich
miteinander anstatt immer mehr Waffen zu
liefern dazu sofort der Kommentar von
Jürgen Töpper über Youtube mit wem denn
reden Papier ist auch geduldig und
Gunnar Geck schreibt über Facebook es
ist schon ein Unterschied ob man einen
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg
unterstützt oder die Verteidigung gegen
einen solchen das sind ja auch Meinungen
Kommentare die eben auch wichtig sind
allerletzte Frage die USA versuchen sich
weniger abhängig zu machen ich
formuliere es vorsichtig weniger
abhängig zu machen von China indem sie
sagen wir investieren mehr zu Hause
benutzen mehr Rohstoffe von zu Hause so
der vorsichtige Plan von beiden hatte
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg wird
eigentlich nicht müde immer wieder zu
wiederholen zu sagen nach der Erfahrung
was eine Energie Abhängigkeit von
Russland letzten Endes für den besten
bedeutet sollte man doch daraus gelernt
haben und versuchen die Abhängigkeit von
China zu reduzieren aber die deutsche
Abhängigkeit von China hat in der
bisschen Zeit in den letzten Monaten
sogar noch zugenommen wie sehen Sie das
denn als China Experte hat Deutschland
da nicht gelernt ist es völlig unmöglich
ähnliches zu tun sich unabhängiger zu
machen
ich glaube es wurde gelernt sowohl in
der Wirtschaft als auch in der Politik
die Hausaufgaben sind groß und der
Versuch ist da auf allen Seiten etwas
stärkere Resilienz in die Beziehung mit
China reinzubekommen dass die risking
und die Diversifizierung sind da die
Schlagworte da geht es nicht um eine
vollständige entlechterung von China
aber in die Verflochtenheit eben mehr
Sicherheit reinzukommen das ist eine
riesen Aufgabe ist auch für viele
Unternehmen überhaupt noch nicht durch
dekliniert im Einzelnen was das genau
bedeutet wir haben kritische
Abhängigkeiten mit Blick auf Rohstoff
Zulieferung aus China sind in vielerlei
Hinsicht auch sehr stark verflochten und
durchaus strategisch mit Blick auf
einige Zukunftstechnologien also hier
gibt es einen ein Hausaufgabenheft was
groß ist ich glaube Unternehmen und die
Politik wagen sich da langsam daran ob
das zeitnah und rechtzeitig vor an
diesen tiefen diopolitischen Brüchen vor
denen wir stehen noch geschehen kann das
ist eine glaube ich wichtige Frage aber
der Versuch scheint mir mittlerweile